here are a few stories we think you'll
be talking about today Ford Motor
Company is being sued by police officers
who claimed they were poisoned because
of an alleged design flaw in some of the
automakers vehicles six Washington State
Troopers filed the class action suit
Wednesday they alleged their Ford
Explorer cruisers have a defect that
allows exhaust fumes containing carbon
monoxide to get into the passenger
compartment that allegedly caused them
to experience symptoms like headaches
nausea and foggy thinking in a statement
Ford said safety is one of its top
priorities
it also says an internal investigation
found the carbon monoxide concerns are
related to unsealed holes in the
vehicles made from the installation of
police equipment by third parties so
it'll be interesting to see what happens
here in one of the troopers actually
suffered permanent neurological damage
and can no longer at work Kris Van
Cleave been reporting on one of the
first cases was an officer who allegedly
was behind the wheel responding to a
call and then passed out I mean that
beyond the damage that could be done
there it's it but for that officer but
everybody else frightening on so many
levels so what to see all these lawsuit
plays out